[Musique]
la campagne entre dans son dernier droit
monnaies comme une candidate à la mairie
y met toute son énergie
auparavant une journée de pluie comme
celle ci aurait pu lui causer bien des
soucis
propriétaire d'une résidence située en
zone inondable
elle a dû s'adapter pendant des années à
la crue des eaux en 2012
l'ouragan szendy a été l'épisode de trop
les communes et sa famille ont décidé de
déménager dans une autre ville une
décision difficile mais qui devenait
inévitable
sa maison a été achetée par l'état du
new jersey avant d'être détruite
c'est un retour à l'état naturel
explique stacy hoffman qui gère le
programme de rachat dans le comté de
woodbridge
un espace tampon qui permettra de mieux
absorber l'eau en cas d'inondation pour
que le projet fonctionne il faut donc
qu'un groupe de propriétaires acceptent
de partir dans ce quartier plus de 150
maisons ont été achetées et démolit un
scénario qui attend une trentaine
d'autres résidences l'offre du
gouvernement
acheté la propriété selon sa valeur
avant le passage de samedi surtout que
le programme fonctionne sur une base
volontaire et que les montants offerts
n'ont pas convaincu tout le monde
de six marches l'escalier de débit
papier est passé à 14
elle aurait voulu vendre mais elle a
plutôt choisi d'élever sa résidence avec
l'aide de ses assurances son hypothèque
était trop importante et bien que l'état
proposé de négocier l'effacement de sa
dette avec sa banque
ce n'était pas assez des investissements
perdus et rien pour l'achat d'une
nouvelle maison
au new jersey le programme a permis le
rachat de plus de 700 résidences mais
dans certaines régions de l'état
cette option n'a jamais été envisagé la
maison de juma gino a pourtant été
durement endommagée par cindy pour
adapter sa résidence il a touché 150
mille dollars par le biais d'un
programme gouvernemental obtenir ces
fonds a été un véritable calvaire
administratif mais peu de gens ici sont
prêts à quitter leur quartier tranquille
près de la mer surtout compte tenu de la
valeur élevée des maisons pour les
villes d'éventuels départs font aussi
craindre la perte de recettes fiscales
mais ce week end jean djoman gino est
néanmoins conscient qu'avec la montée du
niveau des océans se débat entre rester
ou quitter n'est pas clos pour moi des
communes plus de quatre ans après avoir
déménagé
la page est bel et bien tournée
et bien qu'elle s'ennuie dans son ancien
quartier où ses enfants ont été élevés
monaco mène à complètement adopté sa
nouvelle communauté
tellement qu'elle fait maintenant en
campagne pour la diriger